[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue non passion de plateau
d' interdit d'interdire mais chez moi
confinement oblige pour une émission
consacrée aux tensions observées depuis
quelques jours en banlieue je reçus vous
pouvez recevoir successivement par skype
michel hautbois ancien préfet qui s'est
spécialisée dans les violences urbaines
et et youssef brakni qui travaille sur
les questions d'égalité dans les
quartiers populaires de vision a priori
différentes
je commence par vous michel autres -
bonjour ancien préfet spécialisé dans
les banlieues et les violences urbaines
vous avez rendu en 2016 au premier
ministre manuel valls un rapport sur la
ville de grigny dans l'essonne
et vous avez publié plusieurs livres sur
les sites et le dernier par une dernière
40 ans dans les cités aux presses de la
cité
alors depuis plusieurs nuits on observe
des tensions des heures des départs
d'ascendis il ya quelques
interpellations banlieues comment la
mise et vous écoutez je pense je pense
tout d'abord que nous avons faim nous
sommes face à un phénomène qui était
assez prévisible et qui est directement
liée au confinement
parce que le confinement créer des
tensions plus grande dans des endroits
comme ce que j'étudie que dans le reste
de la société même si je les connais pas
que de toute façon le le confinement
lui-même créé toute une série
difficultés que nous vivons au quotidien
il en crée de façon plus importante pour
plusieurs raisons la première raison
c'est qu'une partie de l'activité qui
s'y déroulent kg est marginale mais mais
importante quelle activité délinquante
et elle même mise en difficulté par le
confinement pour dire clairement les
personnes les individus qui pratique le
commerce de stupéfiants n'ont plus de
consommateurs dont plus d'acheteurs et
non plus de 10
deux distributeurs n'ont plus de
livraisons et donc aujourd'hui ils ont
des ils ont une difficulté ou vivre sans
doute aux modes d'habitat dans une
partie de ces quartiers où les jeunes
garçons culié dans des appartements avec
parfois des mots un peu nombreuses et
puis surtout dans des familles où il est
assez rare que les filles et les garçons
soient confinés dans les mêmes espaces
est bon au même moment et donc la
tentation est assez grande pour ces
jeunes garçons qui il faut bien dire
habituellement vivent une grande partie
de leur temps pour comble au puy à la
loi commune qui est de rester
aujourd'hui dans des appartements le
pardon mais pour quelles raisons ces
garçons dont vous parlez ne vivrait pas
tout même heure avec leur soeur ou avec
leur mère pour quelles raisons
est ce que c'est évidemment on peut pas
généraliser parce que les pratiques sont
assez différentes selon selon les
familles et selon les origines des
populations mais
dans ces quartiers vous avez une partie
de la population qui a l'habitude de
séparer à ses vêtements la halle à vider
des filles qui elles mêmes d'ailleurs
sont parfois confiné
plus souvent qu'à leur tour et puis des
garçons qui quand je dis les garçons je
parle des adolescents qui qui en général
longtemps une relation sociale qui
échappe totalement là à l'appartement
j'ai la passion vous parlez de cap
extrêmement minoritaire parce que
statistiquement on sait que dans les
quartiers populaires les filles font
plus d'études que les garçons en général
sont à confiner elles vont faire des
études
elle travaille elles ont peut-être une
vie différente mais mais pas parce qu'on
les enferme chez elle
non et c'est parfait c'est sûr elles
vont à l'école
ll y poursuivre des études en général de
façon plus facile que leurs frères mais
elles sortent pour aller au collège au
lycée alors pour le pouvoir peut le
corriger et le likoud et quand vous
circulez en ces quartiers le soir à la
nuit tombée actuellement le soir tombe à
cet art vous croisez assez peu de filles
voient pas du tout deux filles dans
certains quartiers et beaucoup de
garçons c'est qu'il ya même des
quartiers en france en région parisienne
le père lui en tenir aux croisés
rarement une femme ou une jeune fille
michal et qui est à l'origine des des
échauffourées con que l'on constate
depuis quelques jours en banlieue c'est
un motard de 30 ans roulant sans casque
qui a été blessé lors de son
interpellation par la police à
villeneuve la garenne dans les hauts de
seine il a déposé plainte d'ailleurs il
a aussi demandé que les violences
cessent
a priori ce n'est pas une affaire de
trafic de drogue
non c'est pas une affaire de trafic de
drogue je parle pas il n'y a pas de lien
de cause à effet directement entre
l'incident dont on parle et puis et puis
là temps créé puis le trafic de drogue
ce que je dis simplement c'est que la
tension est grande dans les quartiers
depuis le début du confinement et
rupeni mines est beau même en tension à
cause des difficultés quand contre le
trafic de drogue et pas que le trafic de
drogue d'ailleurs un tout une partie les
autres activités délictuelles qui se
déroule dans ces quartiers c'est assez
compliqué pour moi mais il faut bien
comprendre que je parle évidemment pas
de la population des quartiers
le parc de cette minorité qui crée des
désordres dans les quartiers mais qui
est la minorité qui occupent occupe une
partie des parkings qui occupent ou
partie des voix cette minorité l'a elle
même est en difficulté parce que l épée
liées à l'économie à d'économie 50 ou à
l'économie criminelle les quartiers et
cette partie là bas
la population est à cran l'expression je
n'ai entendu mais c'est assez vrai l
étape en est donc comme souvent le
moindre incident provoque le sitho une
réactivité une réaction assez important
parce que ces quartiers sont toujours
éruptif cet outil là dedans est un
accident de moto relativement banal
convenons-en à le garçon en question qui
est d'ailleurs un garçon qu'un homme de
30 ans on n'est plus un jeune homme
et à une jambe fracturée c'est pas un
accident majeur
mais la situation est tellement éruptif
qui suffit que l'incident soit connue et
évidemment la communication passe très
vite d'un endroit à l'autre pour que
pour susciter des réactions qui sont des
réactions collectives etc c'est ça qui
fonde les les émeutes et les violences
urbaines sur lesquels je travaille
depuis 30 ans maintenant c'est à chaque
fois un fait générateur ou vent qui dans
lesquelles la police est présente parce
que c'est souvent interprété comme une
agression de la police à l'égard des
jeunes et serait générateur qui ensuite
au nom de la solidarité des quartiers
fini par générer des violences
collectives dans plusieurs quartiers la
fois donc c'est exactement le même à
partir d'un incident qui ne s'en doute
aurait pas cette violence mais c'est
parce que les quartiers sont sous
tension qu'aujourd'hui cette violence
est plus grande c'est mon analyse
mais je l'analyse que je fonde de
dizaines d'années de travaux et d'études
de ces quartiers donc et les quartiers
dont je parle c'est ce c'est ce qui en
ile de france en particulier sont sont
comment dire le plus marqué par la
prééminence houleux la présence de ces
de cette activité illégale
voilà donc là on est vraiment on est
vraiment dans un facteur explicatif mois
qu'il ya quelques semaines je l'avais
dit je l'avais dit je l'avais dit je
l'avais dit à un moment d'ailleurs il se
passe est strictement rien je l'avais
dit je pense que la situation va être
difficile alors elle est aussi difficile
parce que évidemment dès que la police
entre dans ces secteurs
aussitôt son intervention est traduit
par une forme d'agression de la police
des institutions en général parce que
les pompiers sans attaquer autant que la
police mais les institutions en général
dans le quartier les jeunes de ces
quartiers considérant que le quartier
leur appartient et d'une certaine façon
n'appartient pas aux institutions
n'appartient pas à un espace de la
république comme on dit de façon un peu
où on est vraiment dans une situation où
ces jeunes défendent leur territoire de
l'intrusion 2e qui peut représenter
l'autorité générale d'ailleurs leur
conception d'autorité est assez large
alors évidemment la common à des
contrôles ou police ont reportés liés
aux mesures de confinement pour une
partie de cette population là c'est tout
aussi insupportable ben arous est encore
plus insupportable que d'habitude et
d'ailleurs eu le l'homme qui n'a été à
l'origine de cet incident rolls un nom
il y aurait pas dû rouler sur un
véhicule qui n'était pas homologuée si
j'ai bien compris ce que j'ai lu et il
était assez naturel qu'ils se fassent
interpellé voilà il n'y avait pas de ya
pas de violences policières à vouloir
interpeller quelqu'un qui n'aurait pas
dû se trouver sur un véhicule à cet
endroit là vous avez aussi qu'il ya des
contrôles qui se passe mal n'est pas
fort ce ne sont pas forcés ça n'est pas
forcément la faute de ceux qui qui se
font contrôler ce n'est pas forcément
eux qui sont toujours dans leur tort
michel bloch
je ne méconnais pas non plus je ne
méconnais pas non plus et je m'en suis
expliquée à d'autres occasions
le fait que les contrôles sont
peuvent être parfois conduit avec un
manque de discernement mais en même
temps il faut bien comprendre que dans
la france de l'anneau enfin dans la
france dans laquelle nous vivons dans la
france d'aujourd'hui est quand même
difficile de demander à 90% de la
population de respecter toutes les
règles de rester confinés et de prendre
le risque d'être verbalisé à hauteur de
135 euros parce qu'on a sorti son chien
à l'heure qui était pas celle où il
aurait fallu et qu'en même temps
d'autres jeunes se regroupent faisant
courir d'ailleurs un risque au reste de
la population des quartiers se
regroupent et son fils
pour l'instant le respect du confinement
est à peu près totale aussi bien dans
les banlieues dites sensibles et dans le
reste de la dans le reste du pays dont
une grande partie des habitants des
quartiers qui sont des gens qui
travaillent et qui d'ailleurs je je le
dis souvent parmi eux il ya aussi
beaucoup de personnel soignant donc une
grande partie des gens qui habitent dans
ces quartiers ils sont confinés où ils
vont travailler parce qu'ils font partie
des professions qui aujourd'hui exercer
leur activité donc évidemment ils sont
ils sont ils sont confinés mais je parle
pas des habitants des quartiers je parle
de cette frange la de la population des
quartiers celles qui créent du désordre
puis depuis longtemps parfois et celle
là elle l'a été
sans doute les échos c'est sans doute un
peu plus confiné qu'à l'ordinaire mais
aujourd'hui ces ex assez difficile delà
de la garde et confient des dons clé une
partie de ces jeunes se sont pas
confinés ils ce sont les retrouver dans
les espaces publics dans les parkings et
continuant de vivre leur vie comme si de
rien était quoi je peux être qui se
noueront mais de la pandémie mais s'est
on peut pas dire non plus qu'ils ont été
les premiers à respecter les consignes
qui était donné je crois pas voilà après
on a une difficulté qu'il faut pas
perdre de vue c'est qu'une partie des
jeunes sont scolarisés c'est des
collégiens ou des lycéens que morale
dans la journée ils sont ils sont donc
dans des établissements scolaires que le
soir ils font leurs devoirs et donc ils
ont moins d'occasions des dehors là il
est évident que la fermeture des
établissements scolaires génère une
envie à ces grands d'être à l'extérieur
ils sont pas les seuls non plus un ne
pas respecter les consignes c'est parce
que je veux dire non plus on a vu des
joggeurs au nombre dans des endroits où
toutes les distances de sécurité n'est
pas respectée donc mais on a une frange
de cette population qu'à l'habitude et
dehors qu'à l'habitude contenu là dehors
pour des activités qui sont des
activités illicites
parce qu'il faut pas renier ce phénomène
qui est important et qui fit vivent
aussi quelques milliers voire quelques
dizaines de milliers de personnes en
france où aujourd'hui se marrent près
n'existe plus cette activité n'existe
plus et a pas regardés quartier pour
éviter que nyon entre la police les
pompiers qui sais-je encore leur
activité est limitée
on peut dire aussi que ces quartiers
sont parmi les plus pauvres de france je
parle de la laddh du département de la
seine-saint-denis est le département le
plus pauvre de france
or il atteint
un record de surmortalité juste derrière
le haut rhin depuis le début de
l'épidémie
comment quand il expliqué si ce n'est
que ce sont des lieux où les habitants
sont entassés plus entassés qu'ailleurs
qui a trois formats de médecins que qu'à
paris par exemple qui a moins de grandes
surfaces aussi qu'ailleurs donc quand on
fait ses courses sont des plus proches
les gens les uns des autres que les gens
ils traiter les travail assez peu vous
l'avais dit il ya à paris il ya dans ces
quartiers beaucoup de beaucoup de
personnel soignant à savoir des
infirmières des aides soignants mais
aussi des caissières des caissiers des
livreurs des éboueurs tous ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui en première ligne habitent
dans ces quartiers dits sensibles
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai alors on a
beaucoup et c'est d'ailleurs il faut
penser parce que les premières victimes
des désordres
enfin quand on quand on a comme ça s'est
passé à meudon par exemple une dizaine
de voitures qui sont brûlés il faut
peut-être s'interroger pour savoir qui
sont les victimes dès qu'elles sont bien
assurés pour le risque d'incendié de
leur véhicule s'est pas du tout sûr
dedans vous avez des gens qui vont
gagner qui a un peu d'argent qui
travaille au service du de la population
aujourd'hui en tout cas parce que les
gens qui travaillent aujourd'hui c'est
au service de la population et qui
méritait pas qu'on leur vole en plus
leur voiture
donc là on est les premières victimes de
tout ça c'est des habitants du quartier
d'abord mot d'ailleurs c'est en visitant
ses quartiers en rencontrant beaucoup de
ces personnes et en gardant beaucoup de
contacts avec elle que aujourd'hui je
prends la défense des habitants des
quartiers mais je peins pas la défense
des habitants des quartiers contre les
habitants des beaux quartiers
je prend la défense des habitants des
quartiers contre ceux qui pourrissent la
vie des habitants des voix là je crois
qu'on peut pas le même alors après qu'on
est bon en seine saint denis comme dans
l'eau partement d'île de france ou de
france d'ailleurs des quartiers pauvres
ça personne ne le nie alors on le dit
d'autant moins que
je pardonne et prête de dire mais c'est
une forme de tautologie parce que dès
lors qu'on crée des quartiers où on met
des pauvres c'est normal que l'écart des
surplus pauvre qu'ailleurs
et donc là ça envoie un autre problème
qu'on va pas traiter ici et qui est la
surconcentration de l'habitat social
modeste voire pauvre voire même très
pauvre dans certains dans certains
territoires quel héritage d'une histoire
française d'une histoire française parce
que ça ça n'existe nulle part ailleurs
en europe et c'est aussi pour ça
d'ailleurs que nous avons des phénomènes
urbains que personne d'ailleurs ces
formulations on continue de les
concentrer dans les mêmes secteurs et
puis après on dit ils sont pauvres ils
sont plus pauvre qu'ailleurs évidemment
on a cessé d eux qui ont choisi
d'habiter dans les endroits où ils
habitent
après sur la surconcentration je suis
moins je suis moins sûr que vous parce
que ça dépend beaucoup des endroits etc
après tout quand on habite à paris dans
un immeuble
on est tout aussi concentré que quand on
habite dans un hlm dans le val de marne
d'autant que aujourd'hui les normes du
logement social permettent parfois
d'avoir des groupes comportement que
personne n'a quand on habite dans paris
donc on peut pas toujours dire que c'est
lié à la promiscuité à la concentration
il faut pas oublier les milliards
d'euros qui ont été dépensés pour la
rénovation urbaine qui fait beaucoup de
ces quartiers qui étaient dans un état
déplorable qui était minable il ya
quelques dizaines d'années
aujourd'hui ils sont sont tout à fait
convenable je ne cite pas de quartier je
les fais dans mon livre
vous avez des villes où vous et moi on y
réhabiliter parce qu'elles ont été
parfaitement bien rénové ça n'empêche
pas les désordres
c'est pas tous toujours lié aux
immeubles c'est a toujours lié à la
forme des eaux
michel en bois vous dit que c'est une
spécialité française néanmoins le même
problème à lui à new york c'est dans le
bronx était dans le queens ce que sont
les qu'ils sont que ce masque les plus
touchés par le corps des virus à
singapour c'est dans les cités dortoirs
où s'entassent les travailleurs
bangladais et même en suède la suède qui
ne pratiquent pas le confinement et où
il ya moitié moins deux morts
proportionnellement qu'en france c'est
aussi dans les quartiers les plus
pauvres et dans les quartiers mais une
forte population immigrée
parce que là aussi les conditions
d'habitat sont difficiles sont précaires
sont parfois insalubres qu'on observe là
encore des taux de surmortalité
moi j'ai pas je compare pas avec les
états unis sur la situation rien à voir
avec un autre comparse simplement pays
européens et dans les pays européens
à part effectivement dans le quartier de
malmö que je connais un peu en suède
ailleurs on n'a pas concentré de
population dans des quartiers
périphériques des villes d'ailleurs les
quartiers déshérités sont plutôt dans
projet centre ville c'est le cas à
bruxelles par exemple donc on à nous
créer une structure de logement social
assez particulier
qu'on a développée dans un certain
nombre de communes de périphérie est qui
et qui au concentre effectivement des
populations qui sont plutôt déshérités
après dans le dans la propagation du
corps d'un virus
le facteur le facteur économique et sans
doute pas le plus important le plus
important c'est sans doute le facteur
population l'homme c'est à dire quoi le
plus il ya de monde dans un appartement
évidemment je pense que plus le taux de
propagation du cours d'un violent c'est
important mais aussi plus il est
compliqué de respecter les règles de
confinement et plus c'est la situation
est aussi fragile donc je pense là où
vous avez raison moi je l'avais rapport
se grime et puis je suis allée rezé
banlieue c'est que par contre on a eu
une réponse médicale qui est très en
dessous de ce qu'elle devrait être
rapporté au nombre de la de la
population blast c'est vrai l'accès à la
médecine de ville est quand même
extrêmement difficile
en général c'est les populations qui
fréquentent les urgences des hôpitaux
parce que c'est pour elle le plus simple
pour voir un médecin
mais les urgences aujourd'hui sont
fermées parce que l île sont réservés
aux malades du coup aux eaux
c'est vrai qu'on a un problème dallas à
la médecine pas fait c'est parfaitement
vrai et malheureusement ça ça ça touche
beaucoup le sait touche beaucoup ces
populations quant au commerce celui même
soyons enfin admettons aussi
je pourrais vous donner quelques
exemples que si des commerces ça
n'existe plus dans certains quartiers
c'est pas uniquement parce que juste pas
qu'il le maire les pouvoirs publics ou
banques tu refasses l'ont voulu un c'est
aussi parce que l'activité criminelle a
tué beaucoup de ces commerces
on a même des villes entières qui ont
perdu leurs commerces de proximité de
s'abonner actuellement impossible pour
les commerces de subsister donc il faut
pas c'est pas parce qu'on est en période
particulière qu'il faut minimiser ce
phénomène qui il faut bien dire pourrit
la vie de millions de gens parce qu'il
ya 10% de la population française qui
vivent dans ces quartiers donc plus de
six millions de personnes vivent dans
des situations extrêmement compliqué à
cause de quelques dizaines de milliers
qui ont décidé de vivre en marge de la
société dizaines de milliers vous via
les peut-être un peu fort non
où en est on à 90 je suis au contraire
très en dessous de la boue vous avez en
gros vous avez 1500 quartier répertoriés
au titre de la politique de la ville
mais moi j'en enlève les deux tiers gens
regardent 500 à peu près qui sont ceux
sur lesquels nous avons des difficultés
récurrentes ses 500 quartiers comptent
environ environ dix mille personnes
vous faites la multiplication et vous
voyez qu'on est très vite et dans chacun
des quartiers vous avez vous pouvez
avoir une centaine de jeunes qui à des
niveaux différents d'ailleurs participe
de ces trafics
on parle souvent du trafic de drogue
parce que c'est le plus visible et
lisible en voyez pas que le trafic de
drogue est évidemment mais qui participe
de cette activité délinquante ou
criminel vous aurez vous pouvez en avoir
plusieurs centaines dans certains
quartiers dans les plus gros des
quartiers au moins plusieurs dizaines
dans les plus petit goût de toute façon
de tout temps on a observé que la
délinquance mais c'est plutôt dans les
classes pauvres que dans les classes
riches
en tout cas cette ce type de délinquance
là ç'a toujours été vrai ça n'est pas
plus vrai aujourd'hui
s'il ya de la pauvreté il ya de la
délinquance il ya du trafic ça a
toujours été vrai partout dans le monde
non moi je suis issu d'un quartier
ma famille était très pauvres eux
je suis pas allé délinquants et la
plupart nous et ça n'est pas ce que j'en
savais pas ce que j'ai dit ça dépasse
que j'ai dix années c'est plutôt dans
les quartiers pauvres
ouais il faut pas trop le dire comme ça
parce que c'est d'une certaine façon de
procéder moi de lire mais c'est un peu
insultant à l'égard de tous ceux qui
travaillent et qui sont quand même très
majoritaire de tous ces jeunes qui vont
correctement au collège au lycée de
toutes ces filles qui dont on parlait
tout à l'heure qui peuvent devenir
infirmières aides soignantes et souvent
plus parce que sur les yeux beaucoup
dans mes services ont préfecture aussi
c'est un peu insultant de dire que parce
qu'ils sont issus de quartiers pauvres
il était voué à devenir délinquants et
je frenche sadefa n'est pas non plus par
don de tenir mais je je je je connais
plein de délinquants qui viennent de
quartiers qu'ils sont allés quartier des
quartiers défavorisés non plus donc il
n'y a pas de corrélation vous pouvez pas
dire ça y est c'est le le trafic les
trafics de stupéfiants il existe partout
dans le monde ça c'est vrai il la
consommation explose et partout dans le
monde ça c'est vrai le poids aujourd'hui
du de l'économie de l'héroïne et la
cocaïne est exorbitant dans l'économie
monde ailleurs ça va être intéressant de
savoir après le confinement est
d'ailleurs à la pandémie 10 qui sait ce
qui s'est passé quoi
de ce point de vue donc ça c'est vrai et
donc des opportunités pour des jeunes
qui sont souvent des décrocheurs
scolaires donc qui sont pas allés au
delà de la 5e et la quatrième au collège
et qui ont pas trouvé autre chose que de
faire le chouf c'est à dire de garder
les entrées des quartiers pour avertir
les les clients qui se présentent voilà
après toute l'économie criminelle c'est
une organisation économique avec une
hiérarchie des gens qui gagnent beaucoup
d'argent beaucoup de petites mains qui
en gagnent très peu voilà tout ça existe
on peut pas dire que ce soit tout temps
parce que c'est un phénomène que
relativement récente dans l'histoire de
la de la société française et puis
on peut pas dire même si on a toujours
eu dans l'histoire des phénomènes de
marge et qu'évidemment dans les
phénomènes de main vous avez fait
deviennent marginaux et donc forcément
dedans vous avez des gens qui ont des
comportements déviants mais il vous
pouvez pas en tirer une généralité ça
c'est pas du tout d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
disons les choses clairement les une
grande partie des vrais pauvres enfants
s'ils sont pas forcément dans les zones
urbaines dont on parle
ils sont beaucoup dans les zones rurales
or les zones rurales provoquent très peu
de 2,2 et l'intense donc on a pas on ne
peut pas vraiment dire les choses comme
ça je crois que ça serait enfin en tout
cas je n'ai vu que je partage pas mais
et qu'on partage pas l'étranger non plus
parce que beaucoup de beaucoup de gens
qui travaillent en criminologie dans
d'autres pays sont arrivés à démontrer
que le facteur la corrélation de la
pauvreté et même d'ailleurs de
l'évolution de la pauvreté et de l'
indice des indices de l'unc ans et pas
du tout assuré à l'écouté j'ai en tout
cas pour qu'on me comprenne bien ce que
j'ai dit je me suis sans doute mal
exprimé il me semble que dans l'histoire
la délinquance se recrutent plutôt dans
les classes défavorisées
mais peut-être que je me trompe et s il
y en a davantage aujourd'hui dans l'est
dans les cités que à la campagne par
exemple c'est simplement parce que il
est plus difficile d'organiser un trafic
de drogue
à la campagne il y aura forcément moins
de clients que dans une grande ville
c'est sur huit voilà je crois que en
fait le commerce illicite ils
s'implantent surtout là vous avez
vous avez une conjonction assez
favorable la conjonction est favorable
c'est qu'il faut vous ayez effectivement
vous l'avez dit des consommateurs les
consommateurs de drogue
ils n'habitent pas trop dans les
quartiers mais plutôt dans les
centres-villes donc vous soyez pas très
loin d'un centre ville
il faut que par ailleurs vous ayez une
base arrière assez solide artisan et sur
lequel on vient pas vous embêter
d'où d'ailleurs les conflits permanents
avec la police et disons les choses
clairement et e
il faut que vous ayez le contrôle d'une
équipe qui vous sont absolument fidèle
parce qu'elles n'ont pas d'autre choix
que de vous obéir voilà si vous avez
réuni l'ensemble de ces de ses qualités
économiques si je puis dire
vous pouvez développer votre business
sans aucun problème et une partie des
quartiers sur lesquels j'ai travaillé
c'est ça c'est à dire que vous avez à
chaque fois quelques familles qui ont
bien compris ce qui pourrait d'ailleurs
tout à fait habilitée ailleurs que là
clairement qu'ils ont une manoeuvre
assez abondante de jeunes en déshérence
qui ont qui ont un territoire qui est
totalement clos dans lequel on dit il
d'entrée même d'investiguer même de
mettre des caméras est par ailleurs vous
avez une base de 1 1
oui ça un ensemble de consommateurs
assez important proche quand vous êtes
en banlieue parisienne
votre zone de chalandise c'est plutôt
dans paris intra muros
plus vous êtes prêt d'ailleurs c'est
assez intéressant puisque les quatrièmes
ont bougé pour le coup là cette fois ci
sont plutôt des cats et proches de ou
des villes proches de paris intra muros
1 vous allez saint-ouen vous avez
argenteuil suresnes sur elle par exemple
me dont il n'a jamais jamais eu de
violences urbaines
donc là on est tout près taille
économique l'autre côté du périphérique
donc si je vous ai bien compris michel
hautbois c'est ce que vous venez de
décrire plus le confinement qui créent
aujourd'hui des tensions qu'on peut
observer
oui c'est pas pour moi c'est un grand
facteur explicatif je crois tout à fait
parce que je ne vois pas très bien ce
qui pourrait justifier
ce qui pourrait justifier d'autres le
sujet alors j'ai entendu parler par
exemple du ramadan mais franchement ça
je lève un élève a démenti il n'y a
strictement aucun rapport entre entre le
ramadan entre les pratiques religieuses
en général d'ailleurs et puis et puis
ces violences quoi parce que le l'islam
est plutôt un régulateur dans les
quartiers plutôt qu'à l'agitateur et
dans les quartiers très criminel que je
vous connais au slam a du mal à rester
implanté en fait l'islam et le crime et
ça va pas bien ensemble
maintenant je lui faut dire les choses
clairement merci merci michelle bohin
portez vous bien et on se retrouve dans
un instant avec mon autre invité
[Musique]
nous voilà de retour avec eux c'est
brakni qui est membre du comité vérité
justif pour adama et qui travaille sur
les questions d'égalité dans les
quartiers populaires et lieusaint brakni
début de tension échauffourées des
débuts d'incendié comment vous analysé
la situation actuellement dans un
certain nombre de banlieue alors déjà
bonjour merci pour l'invitation
là oui bah comment j'analyse bas pour
moi c'était la chose la plus logique qui
devait forcément on a vu depuis le début
du confinement en fait plusieurs vidéos
qui ont été diffusés films et où on voit
des policiers en fait l'écart immense de
déchaîner faut parler de déchaînements
je pense qu'il faut envoyer se déchirer
sur des jeunes des quartiers populaires
depuis le début du confinement on va
être on voit qu'il ya en face d'une
concentration dépenses de police sur ses
quartiers avec des brimades des coups
d'état heures je pense à la jeune rama à
aubervilliers qui descendit de faire ses
courses ce qui a été tasé gaz est
frappée et qui a qui rentrait chez elle
en sang donc comment c'est possible
aujourd'hui dans une démocratie qu une
jeune mère de famille qui descend faire
ses courses sur trophée taz est frappé
au sein et qui rentre chez elle devant
son enfant ensemble des sas et un quart
amène plusieurs de ceux qui travaillent
dans des organismes de santé que
pareille aux ulis qui on est et on
entend des scènes de tortures en d un
jeune homme qui hurlait de douleur et
qui était littéralement lynché par des
matraques télescopiques et donc là
évidemment et ce qui s'est passé à la
villeneuve la garenne bas c'est la
goutte d'eau qui a fait déborder le vase
et je pense que c'est la force de
l'image images on voit ce jeune homme
hurler de douleur au sol avec l'agent
complètement retourné écrasé donc cette
image symbolique a littéralement fait
les choses et il rajoute juste que la
france est le seul pays du monde
occidental où il vient aujourd'hui des
révoltes dans ses périphéries c'est
quand même à noter c'est là la france se
distingue à nouveau il n'y a pas un pays
aujourd'hui en occident même aux états
unis où il y avait des révoltes il ya
que la france
vous exagérez aux états unis à des
révoltes il ya des révoltes mais contre
le confinement et ceux qui se révoltent
sont plutôt blanc et parfois sans même
armés de fusils d'assaut on en a vu un
certain nombre ils veulent en finir avec
le confinement et ils ont même manifesté
devant la maison blanche il ya des
révoltes mais pas de la même pas de la
même pas de la même sorte oui alors il
ya abaissé à moi j'appelle ça des
révoltes d'extrême droite a sont quand
même très limité ça reste quelques
petits coups puisqu'ils sont en plein
jour où ils montrent leurs armes c est
essentiellement politique c'est contre
des gouverneurs démocrates
donc c'est ciblé en fait c'est que c'est
vraiment dans les états où il ya des
gouverneurs démocrates qui ont instauré
un confinement ou donc là non ça reste
quand même assez gentil quoi je ne sais
pas moi une révolte voilà je pense aux
grandes révoltes ouvrières et sait où on
a des des scènes de violence externe un
affrontement à décaler brutale avec les
forces de police on apprend quand ça aux
états unis je pense pas qu'on aura cinq
et on n'a pas non plus de grandes
révoltes en france on a des
échauffourées pour l'instant ça concerne
infiniment que les gens on parle de
crise sociale qui viendrait s'ajouter à
la crise sanitaire duo confinement on
n'a pas de révolte considérable pas
quand même pour regarder les images
quand je sais pas après il ya un
black-out médiatique en fait la queue
aujourd'hui clairement des grandes
rédactions ont décidé de ne pas traiter
ces révoltes de ne pas les films et en
fois par exemple peu les journalistes
qui sont présents sur place pourtant
quand on va sur les réseaux sociaux
et quand on va sur notamment par exemple
le réseau social snapshot qui joue un
rôle très important tous les soirs en
fait dans leur descente ces révoltes
on voit que c'est partout en fait c'est
même à dijon que c'est à tourcoing
roubaix à bordeaux en bretagne dans
toutes les régions de france on a
aujourd'hui un début assez un début
évidemment évidemment ce n'est pas non
plus énorme en tout cas quand on voit
dans ces vidéos comment la police a du
mal en fait à maîtriser la situation
qu'on la police a du mal à rentrer
carrément dans ces quartiers on le voit
par exemple à plusieurs vidéos on les
voit faire des tentatives pour rentrer
dans le quartier il n'y arrive pas donc
ça montre qu'on fait c'est quand même un
assez grand niveau d'entrée de violence
face à eux qui fait que ne peuvent même
pas rentrer dans le quartier alors
qu'ils ont beaucoup de moyens ils ont
des hélicoptères etc
non moi je pense que ce n' est minimisée
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
montrer ses images parce qu'en fait on a
peur d'un effet de base de contagion ou
fait déjà entre les quartiers mais aussi
qui est pas de contagion avec les partis
je pense d'autres des mouvements sociaux
notamment à gauche je pense à tout ce
qui a pu avoir vis-à-vis des retraites
etc pour pas avoir de lien en fait et
d'union aujourd'hui avec de ceux
d'autres secteurs en lutte je viens de
m'entretenir michel hautbois qui est un
ancien préfet vous n'avez pas entendu ce
que nous nous sommes dit mais lui
explique décrit le même genre de choses
que vous mais lui il explique par
l'interruption des trafics de drogue duo
confinement pour lui ce serait la raison
pour laquelle à la fois il ya des
échauffourées
ce serait la raison pour laquelle il ya
des gens qui n'en peuvent plus ils qui
sortent de chez eux qu'ils se regroupent
et puis ce serait la raison aussi pour
laquelle ils ne veulent pas que la
police entre c'est parce que ce sont des
quartiers tenus par les trafics on ne
sait jamais a rêvé compris pendant le
confinement à dire qu'en fait il suffit
d'aller dans les points de vente en tout
cas ceux qui sont près de la pré grille
moi j'habite à bagnolet et un gros
points de vente une des plus grosses
banques tournante de drogue en france on
voit qu'il ya des gens qui te tue mais à
tenir acheté à se procurer des drogues
etc
donc c'est tout ce que je pense que
sinon il y aurait une plus grande
explosion encore si les gens n'avaient
pas leur drogue
je pense que l'association soit encore
plus intenable et je dirais même que je
pense qu'il ya même des consignes qui
vont dans ce sens star ou pas trop non
plus être sévère sur la question la
drogue parce que comme les gens sont
confinés ya un risque que les personnes
deviennent violentes qu'elles
s'entendent à ruch a commencé à agresser
et c'est parce qu'on manque est
aujourd'hui très vite d'autres mais sait
jamais avec sa première chose la
deuxième chose c'est que pour pas et le
confinement le prouve
aucun quartier où les trafiquants de
drogue ont fait traîner ce seraient les
maîtres absolus et la police ne pourrait
pas entrer et c'est ça c'est de l'ordre
du mythe aujourd'hui
ça c'était une idée qui était véhiculée
par l'extrême droite pendant des années
en france est aujourd'hui avec
complètement prise par tout le monde
dire qu'on voit aujourd'hui sur les
plateaux tv des gens qui vous disent que
la police ne veut pas rentrer dans
certains quartiers on parle de quartiers
perdus de territoires à conquérir des
territoires où la république n'est plus
là et c'est complètement faux il ya
aucun quartier en france où la police ne
veut pas rentrer ça il faut vraiment se
mettre dans la tête
vous venez de me dire qu'il y en avait
certains aujourd'hui même où en dépit du
fait qu'ils avaient des hélicoptères ils
ne pouvaient pas rentrer ça je vous
parle dans un cas où il ya des révoltes
dans un cas il ya des révoltes là du
coup des groupes contre la police qui
sont organisés très mobiles
voilà qui sont difficiles à capter pour
les la peau la politique c'était en
pleine nuit là je vous parle évidemment
on l'a on est face à un truc où la
police elle rôde trouve en face à une
résistance donc là c'est normal mais
sinon temps normal moi on sait très bien
la police pour entrer n'importe où a pu
faire des perquisitions
elle peut aller arrêter la preuve avec
des arrestations et une fois une
vingtaine d'arrestations
hier soir donc donc c'est possible pour
la police de rentrer partout et on sait
image aujourd'hui qui tombe par tous les
partis de france où on voit les
policiers se déchaîner contre des jeunes
montrent qu'ils peuvent rentrer par tous
montrent qu'ils sont maîtres en fait
absolue dans les quartiers populaires il
pourrait pas traîner des personnes comme
sa surprise en maître fibré pas les
lyncher pourrait pas d'ectasy pourrait
pas les gas x etc
donc c'est la preuve qu'il n'ya pas de
quartier aujourd'hui où ils nous battent
pas entre la résistance quand on donne
de ces quartiers se révolte légitime
m'enfin ça ces actes et bien évidemment
que là ils ont ils ont une résistance en
face ils ne peuvent pas montrer comme il
audoli dont il savourait cne si je vous
comprends bien s'il ya des problèmes
détention aujourd'hui en banlieue c'est
la faute des policiers ce n'est pas la
faute de la pauvreté de ces quartiers de
la surmortalité duo cornet virus du fait
que les gens sont entassés plus nombreux
qu'ailleurs
qu'il ya moins de médecins moins de
grandes surfaces pour se ravitailler qui
a plus d'obèses aussi plus de plus de
malades du diabète dans ces quartiers
pauvres que qu'ailleurs dessus en fait
on est dans l'initiation donc en 2005
puisque rien absolument rien n'a changé
en fait vous savez ça a même empiré et
c'est à dire qu'on fait là évidemment
que la police c'est juste un révélateur
de toutes choses ça que la police c'est
l'étincelle
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure d'étincelles
qui fait voilà la goutte d'eau qui fait
déborder et donc en fait pour préférer
la police n'est que le déclencheur d'un
malaise général et des inégalités qui
sont évidemment structurel ou jourd'hui
dans les quartiers populaires et plus
particulièrement dans le 93
en seine saint denis donc évidemment que
ce n'est pas que la police évidemment qu
en 2005 c'est la mort de zyed et bouna
mais ce n'est pas que cela c'est tout un
ensemble de choses où on a vu par
exemple des gens qui parlaient
évidemment qui déchirer leur carte
d'identité qui sont des pas français et
c'est extra c'est plein de choses qui
font que évidemment que ça que ça
explose quand vous parlez de la
surmortalité aujourd'hui dans le 93
mais évidemment aujourd'hui on a une sur
mentalité parce que quand vous venez de
le dire non on le sait que le corps n'a
du russe est mortel pour les personnes
en surpoids pour des personnes qui ont
des maladies chroniques des maladies
cardiovasculaires évidemment les
questions diabète et quand on regarde
les chiffres et qu'on transpose des
maladies aujourd'hui survolé mort du
canda virus envois que c'est parti c'est
les endroits où il ya le plus de
personnes qui sont atteintes de ces
maladies ont forcément week end est
forcément et moi moi je pense que la
question qu'on doit tous ces corps ça
n'explose pas avant de dire qu'en fait
on devrait s'étonner du fait que ce soit
aussi calme en fait parce que quand on
regarde aujourd'hui dans le 93 tu as
donc comme des affaires que ban de l'est
ici on vient complètement rien dans mon
entourage croit j'ai énormément de
personnes que je connais où les parents
sont décédés
un des deux parents qui est décédé dans
mon engagement à titre personnel c'est
énorme en fait ce qui se passe on se
rend pas compte
c'est un peu comme avec la canicule
quand on fera les comptes après et quand
on verra vraiment moi en fait de ce
virus
on en verra qu à l origine sociale et
quelle est l'origine ethnique des
personnes qui sont mortes de ce virus
dire que aux états unis ont fait
aujourd'hui le comptage ethnique parce
que ces permis aux etats unis c'est les
gars dans bâle iii donc on voit que les
afro-américains sont ceux qui meurent le
plus forcément c'est là
d'obèses sa population on chez le
médecin etc etc
et ben c'est pareil en seine-saint-denis
en fait mais sauf qu'ici voilà jours on
a un peu de mal avec ça ne pas le dire
mais en réalité quand on regarde de plus
près les caissières regard des vigiles
dans les supermarchés etc
ceux qui sont en première ligne ceux qui
travaillent à fedex dans les plateformes
de fret et ses bas ce serait intéressant
de regarder nos origines sociales et
ethniques et enverrait qu'en fait les
deux se croisent les complète scellier
comment expliquez-vous à ce moment là
puisque vous avez fait allusion aux
émeutes de 2005
rien n'a changé dit vous pourtant de
l'argent a été dépensé depuis plus de 15
ans y compris dans le 93 et bien sûr de
l'argent dessus rayonna comportement
france mais sauf qu'évidemment c'est
faux de dire qu'il ya plus d'argent qui
dès 2004 dans le 93
puisqu'on le sait maintenant donc voilà
il ya là des chiffres qu'on a qu'on peut
consulter on sait qu'il ya beaucoup
moins de moyens dans l'éducation dans la
santé bon malheureusement il a fallu
attendre deux canadiens russes mais
plein de médecins ont dit que très
rapidement les hôpitaux étaient saturées
qui n'avaient pas les moyens de faire ça
ce que évidemment il ya moins de
médecins par habitant dans 93 il ya
moins de possibilités de faire de la
prévention en amont pour détecter les
maladies etc
les gens n'ont pas d'argent les gens
vont moins chez le médecin etc etc
et donc oui forcément ça a empiré
bien sûr sébastien c'est bien pire et en
tout cas il faut vraiment cessé avec
celui de l'argent quand on déverserait
par milliards dans le 93
puisqu'on le sait que c'est faux il ya
moins de services publics les transports
sont moins bien que tu allais pas
vraiment bien dotée en transports
publics etc
et c'est donc en rencontres regarde par
ailleurs la banlieue ouest ou même paris
intra muros
on voit qu'il ya beaucoup plus de moyens
on sait que la qualité de l'enseignement
public par exemple est bien meilleur
dans paris parce qu'il ya plus de moyens
tout simplement parce que les profs par
exemple les meilleurs profs de les
agréger qui coûte plus cher leçons dans
paris sont pas en seine saint denis et
voilà on sait qu'aujourd'hui il ya des
collèges ou par exemple au début du
conte du confident de moi je suis propre
en seine-saint-denis a bondi et on avait
même pas de quoi se laver les mains
pas de jeu
deux tables c'est super on avait des
conditions désastreuses d'enseignement
dès le début de l'épidémie
alors que dans le même temps le
ministère nous disait apprenez aux
bolets laver les mains en découlent
jérôme on est tellement grand deux
petites foires se mouiller et le plus de
monde mais il faut que ces c'est avec
cela c'est faux et toutes les études
sérieuses de monde je savais comment
expliquez-vous que certain nombre
d'incidents récents se soit déroulé
justement dans le 92 et pas dans le 84
92 étant le département le plus riche de
france a fait ça pour être même un
départ en état autonome comme j'ai
pasqua et vous aurez remarqué quand même
que c'est les poches de pauvreté dans le
c'est sûr que vous savez le bronx de
queen s'exerce à côté de manhattan
c'est pas si loin en fait c'est même le
centre de la ville de new york
mais il savait c'est très facile les
études urbaines le montre compte de
créer des poches de pauvreté des poches
complètement hermétique dans lequel se
développe une extrême précarité in
extrêmement strictes et sans aucun
problème donc en fait sur un chantier
que c'est villeneuve la garenne et
gennevilliers et asnières et c'est comme
ça y'a pas de problème c'est dans 93 on
a le logis du 93 en alors ainsi un qui
est très riche où il ya énormément de
personnes de qui paye lier cet extrait
pas qu'ils paient jss que ça n'existe
plus et ça n'empêche pas à fontenay sous
bois
pareil à fond d'espoir il ya eu des
révoltes si je prends la dernière nuit
et pourtant on a une partie qui est
frontalière avec vincennes et qui est
très riche
donc il n'ya pas de problème en fait
créer des pauvres des poches de pauvreté
mais le 93 ans j'étais c'est un
département où il ya énormément
d'entreprises
il ya énormément d'entreprises qui
payent des impôts etc oui car énormément
de richesse du site y est produite mais
on a un des inégalités systémique un
racisme systémique qui empêche les
personnes d'avoir accès au marché du
travail d'avoir accès au logement etc
il fait bon être mais ça fait à peu près
un mois depuis le début du confinement
qu' on ne parle plus tellement des
musulmans dans les médias on a parlé des
chrétiens évangélistes qui serait
responsable de la deux du défi
l'épidémie autour de mulhouse
on a parlé des catholiques intégristes à
saint nicolas du chardonnet qui
s'étaient rassemblés pour célébrer une
messe en dépit de l'interdiction on
parle des juifs orthodoxes qui pose des
problèmes à jérusalem mais pas des
musulmans
or le ramadan commence va-t-on commencé
à parler des musulmans qui ne
respecteraient pas le confinement est
peut-être va-t-on en parler suite à ces
incidents en banlieue
ah oui bon il ya eu quelques tentatives
aient eu quelques tentatives avec
zemmour un peu par ci par là à droite à
gauche j'ai essayé de lancer quelques
petites polémiques sur les musulmans
il a quand même essayé faut comme le
reconnaître il ya quelques animateurs
télé aussi sur ses new skies ont essayé
de poser des questions à des hommes
politiques sur des musulmans qui pose
des problèmes c'est un essaim ne prend
pas en fait parce qu'il ya un moment
donné ou dont les gens voient bien que
c'est ridicule là effectivement vous
avez raison le problème en france début
d'un rassemblement évangéliste à
mulhouse et même la corée d'ailleurs etc
auraient été infectés parce que c'est
des gens qui sont revenus d'un
rassemblement évangéliste ont chiné qui
ont contaminé la corée qui sont entrés
clandestinement au corps est donc là
pour le coup on se dirige en outre la
paix évidemment je crois que c'est jean
luc mélenchon qui avait tout et si
ç'avait été des musulmans qui avait
lancé l'épidémie on aurait eu des
reportages et des reportages des
reportages il ya comme sur ces luttes
comme ce qui veut dire un jeu beaucoup
de cul pour ses news mais où il était
question de ce que le ramadan de ramadan
doit être annulée c'était une quelconque
question de fond un débat important
atout leur parlant pas être rédigé
évidemment il sera pas annulé maintenant
parce que voilà ça ne change rien le
confinement sera juste une occasion
supplémentaire de valade être dans une
méditation de lire beaucoup et c'est ça
n'empêche en rien de voilà de jeu car le
ramadan en fait de faire le jeune
évidemment il y aura pas de prière
collective le soir puisque évidemment
les musulmans sont des sons comme le rsa
population il respecte le confinement
d'ailleurs lé préfet le disent c'est pas
moins respectées qu'ailleurs d'ailleurs
quand on regarde ça serait intéressant
de regarder aussi le profil sociologique
d un million de franciliens pour quitter
l'île de france qui ont été précédemment
la région juste un an que
soit décrété de confinement 1 parce qu
on sait maintenant ils sont déplacés
massivement et donc qu'ils ont dû
forcément dépassé le virus avec eux je
suis sûr qu'on verrait qu'il ya très peu
de personnes de la seine saint denis
parmi ces personnes ou devine la garenne
et donc donc voilà donc avec des
tentatives ça n'a pas pris mais quand
même il ne faut pas oublier que voilà on
n'est pas l'abri et surtout avec ces
révoltes effectivement on est peut être
tenté de dire qu'on a en face à un truc
un peu d c'est comment comme on l'avait
dit en 2005 vous avez des réseaux
islamistes et c est ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'en 2005 avait eu un
rapport du renseignement des
renseignements généraux qui avait été
commandée par sarkozy à l'époque qui est
très intéressante pouvez relire à
nouveau dans journal le monde et qui
expliquait très bien que la raison de
bénévoles c'était des raisons clairement
sociale et il avait dit que tant qu'on
ne règlera pas la question des
inégalités sociales s'est dirigé qui le
disent un ton qu'on n'en arrivera pas là
question des églises social d'autres
révèlent trop bien drôle de manière
épisodique comme ça et c'est quand qu'on
n'aura pas réglé structurellement le
problème est la réponse de nicolas
sarkozy après avoir reçu ce rapport
c'est qu'il a enterré ce rapport et il a
viré le chef des rg immédiatement donc
voilà c'est ça aujourd'hui
alors on paye aujourd'hui le fait que
l'on n'a pas agi à l'époque
évidemment comme comme je le dis la
situation et bien et bien et bien bien
mais il donc voilà donc c'est vraiment
voilà jeu on n'est pas l'abri d'un
retour de l'islamophobie avec ces
révoltes un peu à la mode aujourd'hui de
penser le monde d'après d'après le
confinement d'après le corps des virus
ce serait comment le monde d'après la
revue par vous et est vu par les
banlieues pas déjà je pense que ce
nombre est en tout cas moi je suis au
comité des juristes comité à la main je
pense que ce qui serait bien c'est de
regarder le présent maintenant tout de
suite de regarder le présent le mythe de
regarder ce qu'elle était auparavant et
c'est à dire que au lieu de se projeter
dans des scénarios complètement
grotesque ap / ou en fait on va un peu
transposés ses fantasmes en fait on va
dire que ça va changer on va tout sera
prêt fin mai sur ne seront plus jamais
comme avant
évidemment ça je n'y crois absolument
moi je ne crois absolument pas que les
choses vont changer
je pense même que ça peut être pire je
pense même que mac on l'a bien senti de
cette situation tous ceux qui pensent
qu'après il va avoir des crampes des
grands mouvements etc
moi je n'y crois absolument pas
un changement radical structurelles et
ça je n'y crois pas parce que j'aurais
déjà ce qui se fait aujourd'hui est donc
faut regarder aujourd'hui ce qui se
passe donc là il ya des révoltes là qui
sont là dans toute la tente ou du
quartier de france tout le monde en fait
en vérité une sans s'en moque notamment
les grandes figures de la gauche
j'arrive aujourd'hui très peu de
commentaires très peu de l'analyse fine
sur cette situation de tous les
responsables de gauche quel qu'il soit
et donc je vois pas comment on peut se
projeter vers l'avenir sans parler de ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui devant les yeux
et et surtout moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est que en fait c'est de voir que
quand on parle de la seine-saint-denis
et qu'en réalité la sésamie c'est un
département qui a été longtemps très à
gauche quand même c'est un montant qui
était un département qui a été un
bastion rouges du parti communiste
notamment mais pas que il ya eu aussi
valoir les oscillations mise récemment
la plupart des députés de la france à
son fils vienne de la seine-saint-denis
donc en fait en réalité quand moi
j'analyse la gauche a là aussi une
responsabilité dans ce qui se passe dans
ce département
ce qu'ils ont été aux commandes c'est
des gens qui ont tous la région était de
bush le département était de gauche
pendant très longtemps il était comme
istres il est passé socialiste
les mairies et emma majoritairement des
mairies communistes socialistes
et qu'est ce qu'elles ont fait en fait
moi pour moi quand j'analyse et quand
j'aurai par exemple à bagnols et quand
je vois l'action ici de la gauche
abandonné c'est qu'elle a été concentré
que sur une seule chose c'est d'empêcher
que les quartiers populaires sans gagner
politiquement et de manière autonome
c'est dire que la hantise de ses
mouvements c'est qu'en fait ils se
disent jamais et deviennent autonomes
jamais ils ont leur propre mouvement
politique
en fait ils n'ont plus besoin de nous
ils voteront plus pour nous parce qu'en
fait la seule façon qui l'ont
d'appréhender les quartiers populaires
c'est de les voir en terme de réservoir
électoral c'est qu'elles voient ils vont
m'apporter quelle communauté d'inventer
telle voix etc etc etc et donc en fait
c'était la seule approche qu'on a fait
des quartiers et quand des militants
comme moi mais comme d'autres essais
organisés politiquement essaye de créer
une autonomie politique dans les actions
dans la solidarité etc
mais des luttes aussi sur les ascenseurs
son logement digne contre la police
contre le racisme et c'est ce qu'on a en
face de nous c'est par l'état forcément
ses palais
droite la droite avec les mouvements de
gauche parce qu'ils ne veulent pas que
des mouvements politiques émergent de
ces quartiers populaires
ça c'est quelque chose je pense que
c'est là franchement c'est leur plus
grande hantise
mais moi je le vois ici concrètement par
exemple on à alexis corbière que député
de la france assure medicine qui n'a eu
de cesse plus tôt d'entraver toute
émergence politique des quartiers
populaires plutôt que la limite de
l'encourager ou se faire le porte-voix à
l'assemblée de quelle le mouvement
politique
parlez vous ce serait sur la base sur
une base communautaire communautariste
donc c'est les blacks panthers c'est les
partis qu'ils ne recruteraient que des
gens issus de l'immigration
non pas du tout on part en fait ce qu'il
faut partir quand on parle vous savez
des luttes locales on parle de ce qui
est la réalité locale
on peut s'inventer une vie on peut dire
voilà on va prendre tout le monde
évidemment tout le monde est bienvenu
parce qu'en fait le québec c'est la
justice ça qu'on crée une communauté qui
est basée sur l'exigence de justice et
d'égalité
c'est ça qui compte là nous serons les
mouvements de lutte contre les crises
assez vérité et justice
on veut la vérité on veut la justice
c'est ça en fait c'est ça le maître mot
c'est qu'on réclame l'état de droit la
justice et que les policiers soient
jugés comme les autres cantons à cette
base là tout le monde est bienvenu cité
pour la justice tu tu es le bienvenu
mais il ya une réalité dans les
quartiers populaires quelle est cette
réalité c'est qu'on a parqué les mêmes
gens les gens de l'amd même coup leur
ensemble
c'est ça la réalité donc on parle de ce
qu'est la réalité alors évidemment quand
tu vas essayer de rassembler ceux qui
sont discriminés à cause de leur couleur
de peau
les noirs les arabes les bras mais tu
sais on va le traiter de communautarisme
et sur ce que moi je prends la réalité
qui est là qui devront que je fais avec
ce que j'ai là quand on a un problème
d'ascenseur sur une tour de 18 étages
pendant trois ans et c'est avec tout le
monde on a rien à faire mais absolument
rien à traire et que du coup tu te met
en mouvement pour faire en sorte que des
gens puissent vivre dignement et que du
coup tu le fait que les habitants de
cette tour bah tu te rends compte que
j'avais tendance à tout sont
majoritairement maria oui c'est comme ça
et pourtant péché notamment par exemple
de mener cette lutte une des armes qui
va qui vont utiliser pour te bizarrement
c'est de dire tu es communautariste
c'est de dire que sa guise c'est à dire
que voilà tu te rends ferme etc
alors que toute personne qui pour la
justice et le bienvenu je veux si tu
allais
les panthers mais on sait que leur
action a été efficace dans les quartiers
les plus pauvres noirs américains dans
les années 60 70
vous y pensez vous des pas contents
c'est carrément une référence en fait
les bacs mental c'est une référence
claire pour tous ceux qui aujourd'hui se
mobilisent dans les quartiers populaires
sont venus dans les quartiers populaires
notamment les dix points les dix
commandements entre guillemets 10 relais
des revendications des black panthers
mais aussi la manière de s'organiser par
exemple faut savoir que il partait
vraiment des réalités concrètes
ce qui me parle beaucoup il y avait un
problème il avait remarqué qu'ils
entrent en noir ne mangeait pas le matin
il n'avait même pas d'autre idée de
petit déjeuner danoise était pauvre et
bien tu estimes enfin ils vont mettre en
place des petits déjeuners le matin pour
tous les enfants droit avant qu'ils
partent à l'école ça c'est un exemple il
avait mis en place aussi des cliniques
voilà de la médecine etc pour pouvoir
même pas pour permettre justement ces
populations qui n'ont pas accès à la
médecine dit avoir accès etc
des cours de droit des cours sur
l'histoire noire mais sur l'histoire de
décolonisation de l'afrique et ses
textes c'est évidemment ça c'est une
référence pour nous c'est ce qu'on
essaye de faire nous avec le comitat
demain et je pense qu'en évidemment avec
notre contexte qui est français en fait
avec ce qu'il ya devant 2 au 6 mai par
exemple les colocs le comitat damas on
s'est beaucoup inspiré de ce qu'ils ont
fait notamment du mouvement hippie ou
îlots contre la guerre du vietnam où ils
ont essayé de faire des connexions avec
le mouvement hippie ou c'est ce qu'on a
créé par exemple avec le mouvement des
gilets jaunes ou dès le début au mois de
décembre on a essayé de faire des
déconnexions mais ce qu'on avait fait
aussi avec les mouvements sociaux comme
par exemple les étudiants l'année
précédente à tolbiac etc où assa traoré
avec moi avec d'autres on allait
intervenir dans ses amphis et c'est ça
des gens qui n'étaient pas dans les
quartiers populaires qui n'était pas le
même profil sociologique que nous mais
voilà on a essayé de faire des ponts
parce que l'idée comme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure c'est si tu es pauvre la justice
tuer tuer de bienvenue à nos côtés il
faut tout de même rappeler que la
situation des noirs en amérique était
très différente de la situation d'ici
police américaine était infiniment plus
violente que la liste française l'a
jamais été
la ségrégation les inégalités et est
inscrit dans la loi
en france c'est très différent alors
déjà évidemment la situation est
différente parce que c'est notre
histoire
déjà les afro-américains c'est une
histoire vial esclavage non à une
histoire tout aussi violente
elle est différente tout ça que moi
j'insiste que c'est ça peut être une
référence une inspiration en ad'autres
aux inspirations destinations en france
et dans notre continent d'origine qui
nous traitent qui est notre histoire
commune à tous par exemple des
mouvements anticoloniaux un dire que ces
mouvements là c'est aussi des sources
d'inspiration pour nous tous combien de
là et ils ont battu le real ils ont
combattu contre l'impérialisme contre le
racisme etc
et en fait non ce n'est pas vraiment ce
n'est pas moins violent en fait il n'y a
pas de vraie hiérarchie en france a été
aussi très violent faut pas oublier
qu'en france qu'on oublie souvent et
parce qu'en fait on n'a pas la même
machine qu hollywood avec des films qui
rencontre ces événements etc
contrairement aux états unis est en fait
en france il ya eu ce qu'on appelle des
ratonnades à l'été 74 on a quand même eu
des chasses à l'homme à marseille où on
a eu plus de dix algériens disent arabe
c'est surtout des algériens qui étaient
chassés dans les rues lin shi
comment peut-on comment devoirs aux
états unis au public en france on a eu
aussi une grande marche qui s'appelle la
marche pour l'égalité et contre le
racisme qui est l'équivalent de ce qui a
pu se passer aux états unis avec martin
luther king à selma ou la marche sur
washington
il faut pas oublier qu'en france il ya
un super livre qui s'appelle arabi side
de faustine me semble geo wild 5 5 mais
le nom sur un moteur italien qui
appelait à l'arabie side où il a fait un
travail sur le nombre d'arabes qui a
vécu entre 1971 et 1991 il avait
comptabilisé plus de 200 personnes à
d'origine arabe qui ont été tués je
pense par exemple à des légionnaires qui
doit dans un train qui avec lui un jeune
arabe qui avait jeté par dessus la
fenêtre du train et qui est mort je
pense donc j'ai peiné à film réalisé par
roger exactement exactement mais donc du
coup vous voyez bien que dans il ya une
amnésie collective un peu comme la cua
vous me dire ce n'est pas ses mots avait
lentement dans les années soixante dix
années 60 dans les années 50 il ya eu
énormément de te crime et je pense par
exemple au 17 octobre 1961
ça c'est pas les états unis 17 octobre
61 c'est durant la cinquième république
c'est dans les rues de paris
c'est la police française qui tirent à
balles réelles avec des mitrailleuses
sur des personnes désarmées des civils
c'est le plus grand massacre de civils
depuis la commune dans paris quand même
et pourtant vous voyez il n'y a pas de
90 films dessus on n'en parle pas c'est
pas un sujet et c'est un massacre à
grande échelle
à paris on a jeté les gens par dessus la
scène on les a retrouvés beaucoup plus
loin parfois jusqu'au havre
je pense par exemple à mai 67 en
guadeloupe où pareille en ahl la
gendarmerie qu tirs à balles réelles sur
les guadeloupéens qui demandait une vie
digne
vous voyez donc non les massacres qu'ils
existent il ya aussi une grande histoire
sanglante malheureusement c'est pas pour
faire la concurrence c'est pas un jeu
mais non la france aussi et moi je tiens
à dire que voilà jusqu'à encore très
régulièrement pendant le confinement n'a
eu un jeune qui a été tué par la police
ab 6 1 il avait été retrouvé mort
commissariat de béziers
donc évidemment un jeune d'origine arabe
s'appeler mohamed est donc là encore
vous voyez là on n'est pas sorti et
c'est pas notre histoire ici aussi on a
nos références aussi on a les grands
mouvements de l'immigration ici en
france qui sont des références je pense
par exemple aux milles où vent de
l'immigration et des banlieues est un
grand mouvement de lutte contre la
double peine contre les violences
policières pour les logements dignes
dans les années 90 ça c'est non c'est
non référence
merci et lui sympa crient merci de nous
avoir suivis et rendez vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]